[Music]
in data dollars news Oh submitted by put
tyka on JK news been telling geo to
bring Tyco to JK news put him on the
table like we used to do with our dogs
[Laughter]
he's such a good baby he never cries
I've been here he will cry are you sure
about that
have you heard him cry yeah feel I have
the cutest cry ever it's like I've heard
him almost he always does uh almost yeah
and he stops taking [ __ ] I think maybe
he's just like that's like Bart's
mentality a nebulous no [ __ ]
a recent pop-up store accepted only
personal data as currency instead of
money oh it's starting kind of personal
like my email address social pain number
like yeah like your Equifax number
Equifax it's not good yeah what is
personal data my facebook that what you
like on Facebook your whatsapp messages
your tech text messages photos on your
phone text messages that's kind of like
Gmail dude it's free
yeah like they take all your [ __ ] and
sell it man yeah for the same exact [ __ ]
how do they know you how did they how do
you give your personal data
we're gonna dad's yeah okay so this
cybersecurity firm named Mark acaba
Kaspersky's Kaspersky Lab I hope I'm
pronouncing that right yes Kat Burke
tequila so they ran they ran a pop-up
shop in London called the data dollar
store and inside so pretty much they
partnered up with this street artist
named ben een ein and he created
t-shirts mugs and screen prints for
people to get in exchange for their data
so like what I mentioned earlier like
whatsapp messages your text messages
email conversations screenshots of
things that you have in your phone
photos anything and so in order to
receive something then you have to give
personal data and so that's the whole
purpose of this is to have people
realize that their data is worth a lot
and every day we're giving away our data
for free and so this was just to kind of
put into perspective how much your data
is I love this this is awesome
informing the public of things that
they're ignoring the actual awareness
that we need in our lives
yeah not the [ __ ] awareness we do
for everything else I like when they
have my data because they remind me to
keep buying something that I forgot or
play the video game that you opened up
but you did it really finish or didn't
did you forget how good it feels to buy
things and you're like alright so here's
some images of the pop up the dollar
store they had people standing outside
ready to receive your data
oh no but they did it though that's a
sad about it all these people like oh
I'll take the free [ __ ] what do you want
my social security no I wasn't super
private like that like it's but it's you
know you don't you sound like pictures
on your phone is like can you just give
them dick pics so like you know because
they have these screams on the outside
well this has been mined the artist who
created all the artworks I have your
information the artwork that you had
cool and there's some shirts so and then
print this is the inside of the store so
they had these screens on the outside of
the poster and everything that people
are submitting they they post it on
these screams outside of the store and
they leave it up there for 30 days this
is genius is that a fish tank a fish
tank what's that photo yeah yeah first
thing I wouldn't want anybody to see my
fishes these are someone's what's up
conversation and then some iMessages and
it's a weather like the person trying to
get the merchandise can choose what to
give or like do they like to start
scrolling through your phone and taking
what they want no no I agree I guarantee
you sign their life away no they don't
get to pick they just have to hand over
Wow
but then once once people started
hearing about like what what is it that
they want then people would prepare
their phones and then go oh yeah they
start deleting all the you know they're
cheating they're cheating ways I'd give
my dad [ __ ] it's like all they would see
outside that store is pictures of my
freakin nice oh my god he sent too many
it's just crazy I actually hate the same
kid at every angle
oh yeah no for sure keep getting those
until you give him another grandchild
I'm eat all that [ __ ] I don't care
mister mind you my knees at every angle
possible and sleeping and awake in every
mood damn cool hmm yeah so in order to
get a mug at this store to get a mug you
have to hand over three photos or
screenshots of your whatsapp SMS and
email conversations to buy a t-shirt you
have to be the it has to be the last
three photos on your camera will camera
roll or the last three messages on your
phone and then to get an original print
they force you to hand over your phone
and then a member of the staff will then
poke around and select five photos or
three screenshots that's cool
you can barter with them through those
Oh shot to Niki's but for sure's on that
no no nudes because she won't give them
to me um I'm trying to think what's the
worst should I got my phone I feel like
I just scream shot like really weird
[ __ ] on the internet like if you saw the
[ __ ] that I screenshot you'd probably be
like what the [ __ ] were you doing what
do you do with those pictures I don't
know I don't know I screenshot [ __ ] way
too much you just keep it just to look
at it so like a year later when my shits
like max down I'm like oh my god I gotta
delete 10,000 [ __ ] screenshot so just
like text that's true my whole phones
like Nicky's but and like dank ass means
that's like it I think that's all I got
you know the author of this article they
were saying that they never realized how
much of their personal data is private
to them so they were but this door
really put into perspective like how
much privacy they were really well they
walked out of there with [ __ ] shirts
and mugs you know I mean like that's
they didn't get the lesson to me I'm
glad they acknowledge the lesson after
but the
you don't get to listen if you walk out
of there with Murch bud so you wouldn't
know I mean great did I like many of
everyone here I definitely have given my
information out and I hate myself for it
but like I'm trying to be good about
that [ __ ] and I think we all should
thank you don't give your ear you would
just give your email address to the
random people no I do I mean that's the
part of the problem I always fake it I
get fake info I do that too but but in
our economy we often have to do that
like our bank account yeah stuff like
that
that's why we're gonna get decentralized
homie by Bitcoin thank you
I use one a couple of emails for my main
thing like my life thing and then I use
a separate email for general or like
yeah yeah then I use another email for
people to actually contact me so I don't
I keep the email separate I still have a
hotmail account yep I'm seventh grade
and that's where all the junk goes if I
gave you my yahoo account it means I
hate basically signed into my yahoo in a
long time little pile all embarrassing
email address it's not like sexy
barbeque girl 19 no I've actually had
the same email address since middle
school it's a hotmail email address and
it's not embarrassing it's just my name
and like a zip code so I was probably
gonna find out what also a hall monitor
and I remember my mom was trying to
create an email account for me when I
was I think I was like 11 or 10 she's
like oh what's your favorite thing
you're like what do you like and I'm
like I have no idea she's like tell me
the first word that pops in your head
I'm like what the ring and I she was
like okay what about this other thing
and I just kept telling her it's random
things and she's like now say just
random numbers and I'm like okay and
then that was my email address five five
three I actually got in trouble for my
hotmail address because I had it written
down on a piece of paper and my dad
found it on my desk and he came up to me
and he was like what's this hotmail
thing is
I freaking got so much trouble and I was
trying to explain to him like it's a
regular email out he's like what the
female what is this Microsoft he's like
one who's getting soft on you you just
get like malware everywhere and it was
just like everything was a porn site if
you had torrents yeah and at this time I
don't even watch porn and I got in
trouble for porn because I would
download like all this music and
everything was an ass flying everything
it's like you're watching ports I don't
even get a chance to get my got is
[ __ ] I love to being of that age
where all you want to do is see tits and
ass with 10s tits and ass flap on screen
which is like every kid's dream you're
like clicking out of it yeah against
everything I believed in yeah so
annoying
they made me fight my own like need yeah
click it out in the 14 more look pop
yeah when you accidentally click one
thing god are you sure now it's just Pam
girls everywhere I know [ __ ]
everything's cam girl now and I grew up
in the wrong era or maybe I didn't porn
was very hard to get to back now it's
very easy yeah so you liked it better
when porn was harder to get yeah it was
for excitement yeah it was like you know
I was like playing Minecraft or
something you guys it was like walking
outside in five like five dollars as a
kid that's what it felt like yeah
getting porn cuz it was just that you
had to go through the steps either get
it from homey or you because you can't
go and buy the magazines yourself
somebody else got drugs or something
yeah exactly
remember I remember it was late at night
and I printed boobs and I I was like
this is the most [ __ ] epic like like
heist I've ever done yeah I printed
boobs and we had a black-and-white
printer
back on my dad my dad did the same thing
and you're just running my dad right now
because like he didn't know okay we have
one of those [ __ ] Mac computers you
know the one with the [ __ ] the
colourful table back side or whatever
and then I had a printer and I [ __ ]
turn the computer on turn the printer on
and it's like he was [ __ ] up he was
[ __ ] up while he was printing and
like he didn't know that like when you
stopped the printer and then turn it
back on it'll keep printing what you
like previously so I'm sitting down
getting ready and it's [ __ ] porno
just [ __ ] threw it away and I just
like didn't look at him for a year that
was I was probably early high school
maybe it wasn't in my college but then I
had a budget present went to Davis and
there's this dude that he's so stupid so
you know like on Mac if you have a hard
drive and you leave it open to the
public people can go and look inside it
yeah yeah this guy we're just like let's
just see what this is let's call him
Henry cuz this is actually which I
already didn't like him as much as it is
we just are like let's just see what
said then double-click it open this guy
had archives of porn and I'm talking
about like categorized in everything he
could have opened up his own pornhub if
you wanted to and I was just thinking in
my mind I was I do at this point you
could stream porn you're a sick freak
are you that's true the weirdos new
collections yeah it's weirder than ever
it was like a ridiculous amount of porn
like I couldn't even fathom you know
what I mean like the only way for me to
get through every single video is if I
just gave up my life for the next seven
years right that's what it was like yeah
and then we went into his room to see
what else he had in there and as well
just had like a fish bowl full of
Hershey Kisses which I have no idea my
friend had a terabyte of porn that he
was really proud of he's maxed out the
common yeah we had we had a mutual
friends who and when we go to his our
group of friends to go to his house I
wouldn't do it but everyone else to take
turns go on his computer and just
browsing every collection yeah yeah you
go read the Bible right well I mean
they're all a computer I mean
you would go to community service boy
did this [ __ ] right you got to do it but
they did I love it I do it too in stores
I'm like you know they're all doing that
[ __ ] I mean what am I gonna do sitting
on the homeys computer just looking at
porn yeah it's weird I know one time I
was I was with my cousin and he was like
he showed me porn and then he was
jerking off in the corner and I was like
it's kind of like I knew brothers that
did that as like brothers like they're
just with their moms god they're like oh
[ __ ] mom's gone let's check off these
brothers yeah don't [ __ ] turn on the
video and just start beating on my dad
oh [ __ ] it my Walter witnessing right
now guys are disgusting
yeah blonde Paris Hilton what her porn
came out it was when I was in Riverside
and these dudes were while watching the
porn together on the Xbox together in
the [ __ ] door and that's the weakest
porn of all time you want to watch this
I was like no you [ __ ] weirdo I
bonding time it's private time it's
weird right
that's when I knew I couldn't do no guys
scenes dude hey guys thanks for watching
that last video make sure to follow us
on instagram @ JK films to watch more
videos right up there
[Music]